first up fresh Minister
soup this should be a star hit on any
Italian
menu God very very greasy yeah dirty all
slick around the outside I'll pass on
that one is that oh it's ply on the
stalk next salisia lagano fresh Italian
sausages baked in white wine and served
on garlic
bread oh
dear dear dear um it looks like two
poodles penises D in parsley I almost
like feel I've gone back to sort of
1982 where every other restaurant in the
High Street was an Italian
ripoff we now in the 21st century and
they're still serving crap like
this [__]
disgusting even worse the amoretta cake
is bought in unfortunately not quite
defrosted slightly Frozen in the center
oh dear dear this is about as authentic
as a [__] Chinese
Takeaway right
alesandro you talk passionately about
you know Italian ingredients
authenticity I saw nothing Italian and
nothing done with care I'm concerned
about where you're going how long this
place has got to last and unfortunately
delivered [__]
all that was B way way below par do you
think this is funny
no no cuz I didn't find it
funny I was
upsetting cuz that was [__]
dire Alex may think that I'm his worst
nightmare but this really is my idea of
kitchen hell he's in such meltdown he's
even let the most basic standards of
hygiene
[Music]
slip you think you'd have cleaned up I
mean it's not as if he didn't know I was
coming
there's no excuse for Filth as bad as
this when was the last time the place
was really properly clean it's cleaned
every Friday afternoon yeah [__]
when was the last time all the fridges
were pulled out pulled out um that was
done about two each what about all the
bread rolls down behind the fridge now
you can see them from here look where
she throws up into the oh Al Donna
throws bread up into the basket to dry
out to dry out for breadcrumbs and she
misses so it all goes down the back of
the fridge dirty lady what about this P
of [__] here what about them with a
kitchen in this state Alex risks further
damage to lanter's already fragile
reputation oh [__] H it's never been
used what about these trays here when
were they done last it could even be
clothed down that if we do that the stop
the oven doesn't stops working when we
to change it oh [__] hell are you
ever going to tell me the truth it does
don't worry about the oven breaking yeah
that's replaceable giving a customer
[__] food poisoning is not yeah
yeah look at that in there that is gross
that is [__] disgusting everywhere
you turn in this kitchen there's another
surprise
look muscles on the floor stuff
everywhere produce just left going moldy
again and then there's a pot noodle on
there who the [__] is eating pot noodles
righty there's 60 Customs out there I am
so [__] glad they can't see where
their food's coming from how it's cooked
and what the [__] is going on behind the
scenes cuz it's a mess and it's a
[__] embarrassment [__]
disgusting oh my God that is taking a
[__] piss [__]
hell what is that this is Sala
[Music]
SAU everything from all day English
breakfast hoisting noodles to Mexican
platters this is definitely more
confusion than Fusion some of it's even
served in a bread bin people don't eat
out that surely are you taking the
piss well we we give it a bit of a
Polish 70% of Philip's food is brought
in ready prepared what's happened to
that the Frenchman even gets his
baguettes delivered Frozen [__] hell
and buying readymade food is an
expensive false economy what's the most
popular dish today uh the hamburgers and
the crab yes are they homemade yeah yes
they
are oh finally thank you very much just
[__] rang it Philip's two Sue chefs
mun and alamer are young and
inexperienced they clearly know nothing
Beyond Phil's warped culinary world and
what's that in there sauce Uncle Uncle
Ben's [__] know where do you want to
be a head
chef three years [__] me you better move
your ass all right where have they all G
now I've got table here ready M where do
you want to be a head
chef well maybe in about 10 years time
10 years time yeah probably have my own
place I think that's what I would like
they may be hungry for success but if
they think this is cooking they're in
for a surprise very lumpy that isn't it
it looks like [__]
porridge the bells the bells can you
tell me if this is STA and this main or
is it all
together yeah please because I can't
guess you didn't take an isas the one
which was here was the greek
salad lunchtime service should be a
quick turnaround but with all the
cock-ups the customers are lucky to get
their food within 45
minutes and is not helped by the
fullscale war ranging between restaurant
manager Dave and
Phillip what is it between you and Dave
cuz you hate each other right uh pretty
much
and when the food does eventually make
it out to the customers it comes
boomeranging back just as fast what's
up which
one it's my mistake obviously uh I
should have spotted it before it went
out and it's not just the undercooked
fish that slipped through Philip's net
whated she just said running rich what's
going on here the plates are Fuller
coming back than they are going out she
he said it's not cook po there it's not
what no it's not cook there it tastes
[__] stodgy and [__] disgusting how
many's cooked there Burgers can be
barbecued grilled or fried but the
secret to success is to cook them to
order look how thin they are we don't
cook burgers now they're not even an
order uh we precooking them either for
tonight or even for tomorrow because the
thing is it's tomorrow the thing is the
oven is very very slow and we can't put
it any higher than that have you lost
the plot no have you gone a little bit
[__] bour no and so how you going to
cook that again
tomorrow uh it will be reheated in the
microwave holy
mackerel and the torturous treatment of
innocent food doesn't stop there and you
deep fry the bacon
now we do yeah would you C like this in
France well uh you'd be [__] shot FR
hey they' hang you upside down from the
Al Tree on by your vogs you know that we
in the
[__] well if we want to turn the
business around yes uh I I have to
agree we are in the [__] [__] good
evening have you had a chance to look at
the venu yeah downstairs shita slipped
effortlessly into the role of the
hostess with the mostess any of you eat
macaroni and cheese we do but I'm
telling it's
fantastic C graded my
cheese Brian's taking his first decision
as a head chef pre-cooked buffalo wings
are off the menu from now on they're
being cooked to order chicken's been
cooked from
fresh nice people already place to
turned around in 20 minutes well almost
the rest of the food's going out just as
sherita's always done it hot food cold
plates uninspired iring
salads for that that's shocking and
you're breaking meatloaf
close um but let's not try to run before
we can walk can I get this one as soon
as
[Music]
possible chees how long your time 3
minutes 3 minutes there we are I'll take
that thank you bye okay see you all
right there you
go the restaurant's full but now she's
front of house Sheed using every trick
in the book to boost business 5 minutes
you go right next door to my friendly F
there you go and I will uh see you in
five see you in five thank okay thank
you
okay
Brian 2 hours in and the food's not
going out quick enough sherita's faith
in Brian is dwindling fast these guys
have been in a long time I got kids down
there yeah but the STS have just gone
STS
what happened there with those starters
with those starters they done so already
in the LIF yeah yeah there what these
STS what on for this table these ones no
I'm doing them now oh [__] I just
thought that they're gone man for Brian
three years of living in a c coma is a
hard habit to break he's beginning to
lose
it tables still waiting on their
starters this and sherita's constant
interruptions aren't exactly helping
come on Brian don't lose it now yeah no
what else on this table I need to see
what's on it you got you got hot wings
and barbecue chicken wings I've got the
hot wings I need whatever else is there
cuz they are getting
restless oh
dear all they
order that's it send it
away I am so sorry I'll tell you what
the problem was with fresh food yeah you
can't expect the food to just jump on
your plate just like that we can explain
that to her after chicken takes a good
14 20 minutes to make sure that you know
you don't kill anyone okay has that pig
peek go on cuz it needs to go on now cuz
it takes the time yeah every minute
you're in here we're losing
money [__]
hell so what do you think of that meat
Lo good thank you didn't I tell you
didn't I tell you I thought the kitchen
gol a really good start you were
slightly nervous being down there
because you were sort of not spying on
them but coming up agitated yeah yeah
you lost it Brian a little bit yes a
little bit and things just got a little
bit on you said something interesting
though yeah trud has to understand it's
going to take 3 or 4 minutes longer
because I'm cooking from raw and the
benefit is the customer but I think this
guy yeah with the help of ad0 can get
faster much much faster I mean how would
you sum up you were in the dining room
tonight it felt good because I'm telling
you for three and a half years being
here it was the first Saturday night
that I have spent downstair downstairs
they've seen you you know that's the
first they want to see when they come
they see Mama downstairs I'm going to be
cracking the whip a lot harder it's your
business of course you know and that's
what I was thinking you know I got to
crack it let's go okay thank you good
thank you guys let me go down here and
finish sing cuz I got a few more
desserts to sell this is your canes you
have a olive medon and a cheese be
canipes and a pre-starter this is
ambitious food for London let alone in
vanesse potato soup
with um
Wasabi very
creamy very very
rich I'm excited about the food but I
don't feel comfortable s
here you're like a painter you need you
need you need a good eye you know like
the paint will put something like black
here and not here because for him
doesn't look right okay okay let's go
one scops table n very complicated a lot
of lot of um combinations of flavors
going on for me the golden rule is
always keep it simple you're tasting a
broad Bean a white asparagus and a
citrus vinegarette coffee tomato fennel
seeds fennel flowers shovel salad
parmesan there must be 20 things going
on this plate and then you know that
looks fantastic
but doesn't do anything with him next up
duck on De service this is a duck leg
decided to make it a ravioli on Duck leg
for the n a good um 10 to 12 flavors on
the plate again it's just confusion and
your mind is sort of working over time
to try and understand what's happening
okay service please a main course served
in two parts that's just pretentious
almost like someone
um is uncontrollable and almost like a
little bit carried away and um over
excited and nothing saying to stop come
back o la is that all for me yes is all
Lu seems desperate to impress next
they'll be telling me how to eat it if I
may to recommend you the order you've
got the tiu first please then the
floating island then you'll have the
sufle mhm then the so mhm finally the
Cito with M well out of balance next
going we tell which direction to pee in
because of the [__] salmon in the
river technically Al flavors were
amazing the scallops were delicious mhm
the um light vinegarette yeah um did it
need the parmesan didn't need the
flowers and do you need that many
flavors to make it work I won't change
anything on the flavor I think the way
we work the
product um bring to the guest the flavor
that I want your
personality has to be comfortable on the
plate and I see a lot of uneasiness on
the plate I don't know if you're
confident enough in what you're doing
and I've got to be very honest because
this is very crucial but this this this
this has to
work Barry what do you think when you
think about it it's probably right that
he has
to just find his own style Barry's
acting more like a boted sugar daddy
than Luck's boss you take on somebody
like that and you're taking them on
because of their capabilities and their
ambition and you know the last thing I
want to try and do is restrain that
ambition and and what he's doing I'm not
you know I'm not a chef and I couldn't
do what he does I'm not really in a
position to criticize one c one gr but I
am this place isn't even breaking even
and yet Barry's forking out 4 and a half
Grand a week just on
staff it's no way to run a successful
business